now for the national movie star
recognition test pencils ready
a young lady currently playing a singing
nun and a young man who will promise her
anything will now appear for the first
time together
are they Pola Negri and Emil Jannings
Toby wing and Jack Oakie Debbie Reynolds
and Warren Beatty score 10 points if you
said Debbie Reynolds and Warren Beatty
you only got five points on that test
that's alright I flunked - hold on begin
we're very pleased to present the awards
for art direction for the art directors
invariably discharge their obligations
with imagination whipped and enthusiasm
will you begin please Warren for the
best achievement in art direction a
black and white picture the nominees are
Robert Smith [ __ ] rat set decoration
by Frank Tuttle George W Davis and
uremic Leary for a patch of blue set
decoration by Henry Grace and Charles s
Thompson Robert Klatte worthy for ship
of fools set decoration by Joseph Kish
hal Pereira and Jack poplin for the
slender thread set decoration by Robert
Benton and Joseph Kish Alper our
attendee Larson and Edward marshal for
the spy who came in from the cold set
decoration by Joe szema Gavin
all right the winner is Robert class
worthy for ship of fools and protect
declaration Joseph kiss
thank you all very much and deeply
grateful to all of you people top with
the picture and push a McLintock thank
you thank you very much for the members
of Academy and Thank You Stanley for in
this side
the nominees for art decoration of a
color picture are John de Cure and Jack
Marvin Smith for the agony and the
ecstasy set decoration by Dario Simone
John box and Terry Marsh for dr. Zhivago
set decoration by Dario Simoni Richard
de William creamer and David Hall for
the greatest story ever told
set decoration by Ray Morey of Fred
McLean on Norman Hockett Robert Klatte
worthy for inside Daisy clover set
decoration by George James Hopkins Boris
Levin for The Sound of Music set
decoration by Walter M Scott and Ruby
Leavitt the winners a Jun bucks and
Terry Marsh for dr. Zhivago and
decorations
for John parks and Terry Mars and Dario
Simoni George W Davis
thank you ladies and gentlemen for these
three talented people have been a great
really a great they've just made a
wonderful motion picture out of Argo and
they are certainly not to be knighted to
save me thank you